it's and the US Federal Reserve's
benchmark interest rate his remarks at
the Council on Foreign Relations are
about an hour
here the customer for relations thanks
to all of you for coming and for finding
us even though this is not our usual
venue this is the latest in a series of
meetings on global economic trends and
delighted we have George Soros to talk
to us and I want to before we get going
I should just remind you that please
turn off those cell phones blackberries
and things that go bleep this meeting
unlike some council meetings will be on
the record and George Soros has been
described in many ways my favorite I
think is and this is the only individual
Reza's are in personal foreign policy
but it's actually not your philanthropy
that's the dispute today is rather the
recent turmoil in financial markets I
saw that secretary Paulson said
yesterday that he felt we'd turned some
kind of corner in the crisis when I
checked the markets this morning it
wasn't clear that the equity markets
agreed we'll see what George thinks in a
moment but just to get started I thought
I'd ask a question in this way you've
been a student of bubbles for a very
long time what caused this bubble and
what caused bubbles generally well
bubbles have talked to components
component in reality a trend that is
really happening in the world and then a
misinterpretation some misconception and
that misconception can initially
reinforce both the trend and the
misconception itself so you get these
initially self-reinforcing but
eventually self-defeating processes
because eventually the trend accelerates
and the misinterpretation is carried to
an extreme and the gap between reality
and the and the perception becomes so
wide that it becomes unsustainable and
then the process goes on eventually you
reach a reversal
point now the most common misconception
and actually the most common bubble is
in real estate and the misconception is
that the value of the real estate or the
house is not affected by the willingness
of the banks to provide credit whereas
in fact it is affected and thanks
sometimes some sometimes ignore it and
that's amazing but they it keeps on
recurring so that's the most common and
that's an important element in what is
going on because it's really the
bursting of the of the housing boom that
is at the heart of the current financial
crisis so the banks feel they can lend a
lot because the real estate is worth a
lot but the real estate is worth a lot
because the banks of lent a lot myself
and so you had in this case you had
interest rates too low too long that
encouraged lending that led to an
acceleration in housing prices and that
led to relaxation of lending standards
reinforcing each each other and there's
really been a you know from 201 to 206
and then the reversal and this point
you're making is the more than
incidental interest in terms of the sort
of intellectual consensus around how
financial markets work I mean if I'm
right it seems is there one of the
central assumptions in modern financial
economics has been that investors are
rational they can objectively try to
perceive what assets they're worth and
what you're saying is that there's
always a misperception and this
objective evaluation of asset prices is
impossible yes and and in this case you
have this housing boom which is sort of
the trigger for the larger boom they
call it the super boom which has been
going on for at least 25 years which
whether the real trend
credit expansion that's what happened in
reality credit has been growing
significantly faster than the the GNP
and has been the motor that kept the G
and B growing and the misconception is
what I call market fundamentalism that
that markets are ten towards equilibrium
the deviations for equilibrium are are
random and that markets correct their
own excesses and that market
fundamentalism became the dominant creed
I think with the with President Reagan
in 1980 with Margaret Thatcher came to
power at the same time and that actually
was the basis of the current phase of
globalization so you have had
globalization liberalisation of markets
and then because Marcos don't tend
towards equilibrium and they actually go
to excesses we've had a series of crises
but each time the authorities intervened
and applied they bailed out the failing
institution and did whatever it was
necessary to keep the system going and
that reinforced both the credit
expansion because that's how they they
got the economy going again it's by
finding a new way of fostering expansion
and the misconception that markets can
be left alone because they'll take care
of themselves but of course they don't
it's always the authorities that come in
and save the situation and so if we look
back over the last sort of three or so
decades of financial history there was
of course the stability afforded by the
gold standard up till 1971 then there
was a kind of interim of inflation
stagflation and booming commodity prices
perhaps a bit familiar to people in the
audience now and and then you're saying
that in the Reagan era there
this period of stability around sort of
faith in the dollar facing them at faith
in the American system which made people
willing to lend in dollars more and more
so in fact what you're talking about
also is the status of the dollar as a
reserve currency and whether that may
not get sequestered a this face has been
based on the dollar as the reserve
currency and with globalization of
financial markets actually and the the
Reagan policy at the time of fiscal
stimulus rearmament Act was a big thing
and and relatively high interest rates
attracted the savings of the world to
the center and that's when we started
developing a chronic current account
deficit which has been growing pretty
steadily ever since and reached over 6%
of the GNP and at its peak so we effect
effectively the American consumer became
the the motor of the world economy and
we were absorbing the savings on the
world to to finance that overconsumption
and that could have continued
indefinitely because there were
countries that were very happy to
produce more than they consumed and to
accumulate reserves to build build up
their wealth
first there was China then then then
messer Japan the Asian Tigers a China
and so on so you had willing borrower
the United States will willing lenders
so a chronic a current account deficit
was actually a kind of equilibrium
it could have continued indefinitely and
except that with the housing bubble is
the household sector that became over
over
stand it because they saw the
appreciation of houses as a form of
saving so the savings rate actually felt
into negative territory because the the
houses provided the wealth accumulation
and actually people started withdrawing
equity from their mortgages and mortgage
equity withdraw at his peak was even
higher was about eight hundred fifty
billion dollars I think for nine hundred
billion in 2006 was even higher than the
current account deficit and and if the
housing bubble that is now also
unwinding the the this current account
there is there are two halves in other
words two sides to this long super
bubble on the one hand the willingness
of foreigners to provide learns to the
United States on the other hand the
appetite of the United States to burn
yes
and there's a third the third element
which is the the over leverage
leveraging of the financial institutions
and the use of various new newly
invented financial instruments that were
not regulated and were used and abused
and these were connected also with the
mortgage market because mortgages were
then packaged repackaged sliced up and
again repackaged and sold to to to
investors banks instead of keeping loans
and their balance sheets repackage them
and securitize them so so securitization
and the various synthetic instruments
are the third factor so that these three
elements come together to give you this
super bubble and so do you view
financial innovation is more of a
negative for the
no no III think but it's not an
unmitigated benefit as let's say you
could say that many technological
innovations although not all
technological innovations are
unmitigated
benefit either but we tend to think of
it that way it's not unmitigated because
it
many of these instruments and are
developed to avoid regulation so for
instance if you have loans then you need
to keep the say 10% equity in in the
loans but if you just slice up the loan
and you take only the risk you can take
risk and have it on and have these
credit default swaps there you only need
maybe one and a half percent margin so
you can leverage up a lot more and if
there a way to think for government more
effectively to be able to extract the
benefits of financial innovation we
preserve there as well as mitigating
yeah I think it's basically very healthy
to have this innovation but you mustn't
abandon regulation and that's where
market fundamentalism which believe that
you best leave it to the market you see
that was the excess that led us to the
current it's really the the failure of
regulation I want to prep a little bit
more about the super bubble because if
you look in the data about the ratio of
American debt to GDP there's no dispute
what's happened in the past in other
words debt to GDP inched up very slowly
between 1950 and 1980 there's a nice
graph of this in your new book and then
from 1980 typical parabolic exactly so
we know what's happened the question is
what's going to happen in the future and
you've written in the past that there
are times when a trend is challenged it
goes through a hiccup for a while and
then it resets itself and the
reconfirmation of the trend
of course makes people believe in it all
the more passionately and then the
parabola even accelerates yes so is it
possible that at this juncture what
we're seeing is that at one year or so
interruption in the trend and then the
super bubble will continue because
demand you know the willingness to
provide cap of the United States will
remain there the sovereign wealth funds
the central banks in the Gulf states and
in the East Asian countries that have
all the capital they're going to carry
on wanting to put their assets somewhere
and it may well be in dollars and so
that they sent that is true borrowers
will be found in this economy whether
it's the federal government whether it's
the corporate sector even if the
household sector has tapped out
and then this trend will be a real
setter to be confirmed and will carry on
in this super bubble yes no you are
absolutely right and and past crises
which ever we have had a number of them
were actually successful tests of these
of the thesis of the misconception and
let an acceleration and this was for
instance the successful way of dealing
with the internet bubble the IT bubble
lowering interest rates that then
directly led to the housing bubble so
maybe there is something that that could
be used to to keep this process going
and so it's actually an open question
and right now
actually the stock market seems to
believe that the worst is behind us and
in fact we this is a crisis like any
other crisis and a great opportunity to
buy and it may well be true I I think a
different view but since we are all
fallible and maybe wrong it's you know
history will tell us I personally think
that we have the acute phase of the
financial crisis largely behind us and
in fact
the the authorities have it as their
mission to stop the system from falling
apart and provide liquidity at all cost
and they've done it and they've done it
again
and in fact they've gone sort of past
several new thresholds in in doing it
but they've done it so that is a source
of reassurance that the system is not
going to fall apart however the the
damage that has been done to the system
has to effect in my opinion the real
economy and the effect of that is only
beginning to be felt and there is a
certain time lag because the motor has
been consumers now they they they have
lost their mortgage equity withdrawal
and their housing appreciation and so
they they have to increase their savings
but it takes time for them to adjust
their behavior so actually currently you
know credit card that is still rising
people find other ways of maintaining
their there
living standards or the habits and so
but I think that inevitably they will
pull back and I that process is only
beginning the housing problem is I think
continues to be the leading factor as
far as the real economy is concerned
because just as they overshot on the
upside they will also overshoot on the
downside and they are currently the
house prices are accelerating on the
downside they they were falling at the
annual rate of I think twenty one
percent in December about twenty four
percent in January twenty nine percent
in in February that's an accelerating
rate and to expect that by the end of
the year they you will have passed
through that I think it's an unrealistic
thing because the you've got certain
processes going on with these subprime
loans there are about five million of
them and in next 18 months they are
repacked and they are with just six
months into that process and about forty
percent I think will default this is my
estimate then you've got these option
adjustable rate mortgages the same thing
so I think you will have unless
something more is done you will have
about 4 million defaults in the next two
years and it takes about a year before a
default leads to foreclosure and about
half the defaults end in foreclosure so
so right now you have only got a very
few foreclosures but that is at the very
beginning of an uptrend so I think what
needs to be done is to try to keep the
more foreclosures to a minimum
and I don't think that either the the
fiscal measures or the monetary measures
will stop that process unless something
more is being done it sounds as though
you think that President Bush would be
making a mistake if he delivers on this
threat to veto the housing bailout
package that the House Democrats are
cooking up yes I think this
administration ideologically is not
prepared to intervene intervene and
there's also strong public opinion
against bailing out the lenders or
borrowers who have gone to an excess so
political pressure also so I think that
pressure will have to mount before
adequate measures are taken but it also
seems that you're fairly pessimistic
about the ability of all this official
activity to cushion the economy from the
contraction and consumption that you're
predicting I mean we've had a fiscal
stimulus we've had liquidity pumped into
the banking sector we've had the best
turns bail out we may or may not get
some kind of housing action we've had a
range of measures as you say but you
don't think that's going to be enough to
save us from a recession yes and and and
the markers have taken heart that is the
stock market and we now have a rally and
I think this is a fairly typical bear
market rally and may be wrong but I
think this is it
it is the bear market rally and I mean
obviously the nightmare analogy is with
Japan in the 1990s where the equity
market broke in 1990 the property market
broke in 91 and then it was most of the
decade before anything looked any better
how many years to expect that it might
take two so yes this is yeah that's the
other extreme actually one is that this
isn't you know that we are out of the
woods
and by the end of the week of this year
the economy is reaccelerating and
profits are rising and that this is the
optimistic extreme and the Japanese is
the pessimistic extreme because the you
had the the the real-estate bubble it
wasn't housing but real estate and and
and you had the financial system loaded
down with bad debt but the big
difference between Japan and and and and
us is that the here the losses are being
recognized written off actually some of
the write ups are are even may turn out
to be excessive because you don't have
proper measures use these indexes and
the indexes are but the shorts is
sellers use so they may be way and this
is a B X and the a B X index and so on
so so we have the right house and the
authorities are urging the banks to
recapitalize themselves and in fact they
are doing that
so therefore this accelerates the
process of adjustment so I don't expect
it to last 9 or 10 years but on the
other hand the amount of right now
markets are very ready to provide new
capital but a lot of the new capital
comes in but the activities of the banks
or the institutions will be shrunk
that's why the capital comes in to turn
these those companies into profitable
enterprises so the credit squeeze in in
will continue and also it remains to be
seen whether there is enough capital
around because the the even though the
figures are very large the the losses
that have to be made up for are even
larger
so this is now the question that only
the future will tell there was a moment
in the late 1980s after the Wall Street
Crash and before the economic troubles
emerged in Germany in Japan where people
spoke in quite sweeping terms about the
decline of the American economic model
maybe Bank led capitalism with superior
and so forth I mean how do you how do
your view of of the markets now affect
your view of after the geopolitics I
mean do you think we're in for a period
when people question American supremacy
adds to the doubts of American foreign
policy door exists and how would you
cross that bridge into policy yes
unfortunately I happen to agree that
there is a serious questioning of
American dominance the system was built
on American supremacy and the financial
system even more perhaps than the
political system the dollar was the the
the unquestioned the reserve currency
that is not the case anymore and the
Washington Consensus imposed certain
principles of balancing budgets on other
countries but did not impose that
discipline on the center on the United
States and we did abuse that privilege
by running up this chronic current
account deficit and unfortunately as you
know I've been a as severe critic of the
Bush administration's policies the war
on terror and war on the elimination of
Iraq and so on which really which meant
to to assert America
supremacy in the world and it had the
opposite effect it has it has undermined
America's power and influence in an
unprecedented way and now something is
happening and the financial side which
also there's a there is now an increased
reluctance to hold dollar assets the
central banks don't want to accumulate
dollars they've been diversifying into
other currencies pushing up the exchange
rate and depressing the dollar but
actually there isn't a suitable
alternative to the dollar having the the
Euro to some extent but it isn't quite
there and certainly not the remember and
so because of that there's now been a
general flight from currencies and the
creditor countries set up sovereign
wealth funds now you are right in
pointing out that these banks certain
wealth ones could be in a way the
saviors of the system by replenishing
the the the equity of the financial
institutions I don't think that
politically it will be possible for for
Abu Dhabi and Russia and China to
acquire to put enough capital into citi
bank to actually accomplish it but it
has been a positive factor as far as the
financial replenishing is concerned but
not I don't think it can provide and if
it did of course it would really make
the decline of American power and
influence pretty well official so we've
had a stood a parallel between on the
one hand a diminution in America's
military readiness and it's a very
to project military power and you're
saying also that there's a sort of
similar thing on the financial side in
most countries if there's a financial
shock and the central bank tries to
respond by cutting rates the response of
sabors is to move money out of that
currency and so the currency shock
sort of neutralizes the central bank's
freedom to respond right and the US has
been an exception in the past because
people wanted to hold dollars they
thought in dollars and so the Fed could
cut rates and be the Saviour after the
LTCM incident the russia incident the
dot-com boom and so forth the Fed could
cut rates and rescue the world economy
but that may no longer be the case if
the willingness to hold owners and think
in dollars comes into question that is
exactly the constraint and also you have
what inflationary pressures which
provide the additional constraint so I
don't think we can go back to to 1% Fed
Funds and in fact recognizing the
dangers that that would involve to these
stages of the dollar the Fed has
indicated that it doesn't really want to
go we are below 2% where it is now if at
all possible that's been the the and
that is why actually currently there is
a certain recovery in the dollar because
people are reassured that maybe they
won't be flooded totally with dollars
that the Fed recognizes the limits to
return hard that's that's right that
distraction so I want to go to the
ordinance in a second but just let me
ask one last thing in terms of sort of
prescriptions for how to make the system
safer and people have talked about
moving derivatives transactions on two
exchanges more requiring financial
institutions both banks and hedge funds
to hold more capital as a cushion in
this realm of prescriptive ideas what do
you favor I think the most important
lesson that we need to learn is that
it's not enough to control the money
supply that we also have to control
credit
separately from money and we have to
recognize that markets go to extremes of
euphoria and and panic and therefore we
have to adjust the the margin
requirements and the minimum reserve
requirements that we impose on banks and
and and market participants so
adjustable margin requirements and and
minimum reserve requirements these are
tools that have you that have fallen
into disuse
they've been deliberately left unused
with and I think we need to to start
using them again and central banks have
to accept that they have a
responsibility to prevent asset bubbles
from going too far and they for instance
by imposing higher minimum reserve
requirements and banks when they learn
too much so that's that's I think the
change in in in in the regulatory
environment that's a central change then
in addition to that I think you do have
a specific problem with with mortgages
and you have to find ways to reduce the
foreclosures to a minimum you can't
eliminate them you can't interfere with
the right to foreclose but you can
adjust mortgages and downsize them write
them off it's more efficient than go
through going through the foreclosure
procedure so that's a technical specific
issue for this particular crisis but
generally speaking is is controlling
credit not only money
sir-sir Greenspan was wrong and saying
you should not target asset bubbles
there should be these adjustable margin
requirements for traders so that they
put up more capital when you want to
rein in the amount of investment and for
banks as well adjustable capital
requirements like in Spain yes okay
well let's go to members of the audience
and I invite you to wait for the
microphone speak directly into it stand
state your name and affiliation I have a
question in the front mr. Clements
you're gonna get to in a second steve
clemons new america foundation George I
have read the book and you were a
student of Karl Popper and that
fundamentally your experience with
popper and your thinking about really
this this this question of reflexivity
drove you to do the book not the
financial market crisis but there's a
charming part of the book where your son
says Robert my father is just full of it
he doesn't make investment decisions
like this it matters more and whether he
had a backache or a shoulder ache and
you've devised an interesting thing in
it and it raises the question at Soros
Fund management do you put your student
those workers through school on
reflexivity and and and how do you think
it's best to sort of transmit the
template of your thinking one other part
of this is you've returned to manage
your own account which meant you would
stop doing and and you take us through
your decisions and you have a big rise
and then a big fall and you finish the
book saying we're below water and I'm
interested in since the book came out
are you back above water well several
questions here it's it's always backache
never shoulder ache and it has it comes
from tension and the tension you know
when I can resolve the tension to the
stomachache goes away so it has that
always been true it's that's not just a
story from the 1970s fun that's not just
a story from the 1970s that's always
been the case that you've had still now
you have backache no no I don't have
that game no no no I used to have
backache when I was active in running
the fund and I've had no backache even
though I'm currently more involved in
the market so I'm happy to be out of
that but
that was one question but then I don't
impose my philosophy on others I think
it's it's my view and I may be wrong and
see and other people I've delegated my
money to other people to run and when I
saw this crisis coming up since it's my
money and I didn't want to lose it
I a trading account a macro account
where I counterbalanced what they were
doing
so I offset it I didn't impose my will
on them but I protected my own wealth
and and in fact I'm still slightly under
water and maybe I'll get a little bit
more underwater because I did I do not
buy into the current market rally I
think it's pretty close to having run
its course but while it's running its
course I lose some money ok that's a
question here in the front Alan went mr.
Soros do you think that the Fed has
gotten the balance right in terms of the
trade-off between low interest rates and
their impact and the domestic economy
and the impact on the dollar
abroad have they not possibly gone
overboard and what are the consequences
of a perennial weak dollar isn't it a
form of mercantilism whereby we sell
everything that we produce more cheaply
and pay more for everything we import no
I think that the Fed is right to have
not gone beyond below 2% and I think if
it has to go below 2% it will have
pernicious consequences because they
would do that because the economy is
still in recession they haven't done
enough they have to do more and with the
economy in recession and interest rates
going down the dollar would
would certainly come under renewed
pressure and the fact that they stopped
at 2% is now giving the dollar a
breathing space also so the dollar has
stabilized as a result of of this action
so I think in this in this respect they
did they were slow in starting they they
lagged they were behind the curve
but then the beginning of the year
acting very radically I think they are
now just in the right place and it's now
the Europeans and particularly the
British who are behind the curve because
the fall in the dollar has had the
effect of us exporting our recession to
them because our current account has
greatly improved it has added at least
1% to the GNP in the first first quarter
that's what has kept it in the positive
territory as far as we know final demand
is down below zero and GNP is 0.6
percent but that 1% has come out of the
rest of the world so now Europe is
slowing down and and they are sticking
with their one directional fight
inflation policy question back there
thank you I'm Camille Ceaser from
commerce Thank You Sebastian two quick
questions um the first is how do you
think that the powers of the Fed and
also the other agencies charged with
financial institution regulation should
be changed I have difficulty hearing you
but can you repeat the question how do
you think that the passive regulation of
the Fed should be changed they read
howdy that the regulatory powers of the
Fed regulatory I think the Fed has all
the powers
it means it just hasn't used it because
they had the power furnaces to regulate
the mortgage market and they didn't and
my second question is about the long
term real rise in commodity prices
assuming that what we have is a
permanent shift there how do you think
this change is going to lead to any
restructuring in our economy are we for
example going to become more of a
resource saving type of economy okay so
does the run-up in commodity prices or
go structural changes in the economy
what do you think it's a bubble that's a
very very difficult question with the
commodities because there is a
commodities bubble there's a flight from
currencies into commodities and and
there is a definite bubble element but
then you have different causes as well
in the case of oil I think that to some
extent one can speak over what you might
call it a backward sloping supply curve
you know the higher the price goes the
less incentive the oil-producing
countries have to take the oil out from
under the ground and convert it into
dollar reserves above ground so that's
part of it too and then there's also of
course the global warming and and the
difficulty of increasing cost of finding
new oil so all those things plus the
increased demand from emerging markets
which are very heavily energy intensive
so all those things come together to
create this quite amazing rise in oil
prices and I think that rise is now also
in this parabolic phase where it's
difficult to just to explain it by
anything reality-based
there is something else going on so
that's the bubble aspect and then then
in food global global warming has
affected food prices in two ways
is because of biofuels and the other one
is because of the failure of the rice
crop in Australia now you have the
cyclone in in Burma that again is
destroying the rice growing areas so
disruptions in the production cycle so
and again the improvement in living
standards in the emerging markets so all
these things come together creating the
the these commodity bubbles which set up
inflationary pressures now this makes
the job of the regulator's very
difficult because you're faced with
recession and inflation and that
requires opposite policies and that
again is why this time I think the
authorities will not be able to get us
out of this the way they did in previous
occasions it's one of the things that
makes me more pessimistic then then then
then the markets and Ted Smith from the
Heinz Company
thank you George as for coming here as
one of the leaders of the reality-based
community I welcome you to Washington
the capital of the affection based
community probably no coincidence that
you're here because it's clear that
having read your book that the leaders
of the financial community have no
incentive to stop the boom-bust cycle
because the plutocracy gets rich on the
boom and the American middle-class picks
up the tab for the bust given that my
question to you is what can Main Street
do to tame Wall Street particularly to
enforce the Fed and other things to
prevent the further weakening of the
American middle class well I think
people can vote and express their views
in voting and I want to express my views
because I tried to be less party
political than I have been in past
occasions so that that I think is Israel
it's the main
way that in a democracy people express
their views thank you
you mentioned earlier on the nine
hundred billion dollar home equity
you know the withdrawal I've seen
numbers may not be quite that large but
very large for the few years preceding
that which I assume has contributed a
lot to the growth of our economy my
question to you is can we really expect
a recovery here before that amount of
money has been replaced in our economy
and if if not what is the source of this
equity do we wait for the mortgage
market to reprice and and and more in
the in the home market to to appreciate
are we looking at tax cuts are we
looking at a technology bubble what is
going to drive the recovery I happen to
share your your view that the the
American consumer that has been the main
motor not just of the US economy but of
the world economy is now incapacitated
to play that role so the consumption as
a percentage of GNP and maybe in
absolute terms has to has to decline and
is already declining so so then the
question is what will take it's it's
it's it's a place and I personally
believe that we have a tremendous
challenge ahead of us with global
warming we have to develop non polluting
fuel sources we have to take carbon out
of coal and and and
fossil fuels young generally that we
require the tremendous investment and
which we need to do for our survival and
I think that could provide the motor for
the world economy
it requires the United States to change
its policies towards global warming
getting together with the Chinese and
the and the Indians who have become now
very large polluters and I think that's
where we need to go in discussing the
back right in front of the TV cameras
from CNN türk Amelia thank you very much
sir I have two quick questions
do you believe that the emerging markets
have felt the recent crisis will they
ever feel it and the second one is if it
was up to you to make a decision about
fighting inflation versus growth which
one would you choose at this current
situation to break the pattern the first
one was about emerging markets and I
think that they they are not immune and
one of the reasons why why I'm
underwater this year is because I
overstayed my welcome in those markets
and and the second question I didn't
understand would you target inflation
would if I would as if you were running
monetary policy would you target
inflation will you target growth well I
think you need to balance it and I think
that the the the management of the macro
macroeconomic management is not a
science and reducing it to simple rules
like you know inflation targeting is a
mistake and I think it's it's it's we
are dealing with reflexive processes
there are many different reflexes
processes going on at the same time and
it's a matter of balancing them and it's
it's an art not a science it's kind of
frontier
thank you very much both of you my name
is David Apgar with microfinance fund
manager blue orchard a speculator faces
possible reputations of her best guesses
every day in the market one of the
problems it seems that that we have in
setting our fiscal policy or a federal
budget and it's in in its deficits is
that there doesn't seem to be an
effective learning process we don't get
a quick refutation from the market when
we get fiscal policy badly wrong are
there any ways of of building a better
learning process into in your markets so
that there's a faster readout when
policymakers get fiscal policy wrong no
I think that it's the fate of central
bankers that have got to be wrong
eventually now how long it takes for
them to get to be wrong and how far
wrong they go is probably the measure of
their success how far they go what about
the the fiscal side there what about
what about the fiscal side when
parliaments have a budget that doesn't
make sense yes the fiscal side well
that's that's that's actually more
difficult
and while fiscal policy can be very
useful it usually takes very long time
to kick in and and honestly I don't I
don't have the answer
thank you Steve Charny beds at George
Washington University I can understand
perfectly well the benefits for the
environment of taking positive action on
climate change but you suggest that a
moment ago that there were it be
economic benefits for the economy in in
so doing and I wonder if you could
expand upon on why there will be
economic benefits when the cost of
energy goes much higher as a result of
emission trading and and and setting
limits on if I'm right if I'm right in
thinking that we are heading into a
recession that a research that the
recession is effectively unavoidable
it's only a question of the magnitude of
that recession then you have idle
resources and you need to put find some
way to put them to use to in order to
create the multiplier effect that will
get the economy going and I think that
making the necessary investments in
taking for instance carbon out of coal
generally speaking to to reduce our
energy consumption because a lot of
energy saving investments could be made
you need to put a price on carbon carbon
emissions because that will encourage
investment that will reduce carbon
consumption and that will put these will
be a stimulus to the economy at a time
when the economy needs a stimulus so
sort of deficit financed spending you've
been very patient it's continued wait
for the microphone business
do you think that new administration
could take someone issues and economic
field
financial right to point out that
protectionism is a great danger that
there's a because of the tremendous
strains that we are currently exposed to
that it will lead to protectionism
different differences of policies that
lead to a breakdown in the global
trading system and that could have
really devastating effects so that's the
danger that we need to avoid by engaging
the right kind of policies finding the
proper understanding between the
national interests and reconciling
national interests so that we keep the
system open let's go right over here
I'm globe alignment from the Treasury I
heard you say that we've had in the last
number of years excessive leverage and
perhaps excessive credit and
insufficient regulation and my question
is whether given Arenado de Soto and
other suggesting that in some parts of
the world there's one of the major
causes of poverty is excessive
regulation insufficient creditor
leverage are you saying that we should
permanently have a policy bias towards
more regulation than what we have
and less credit expansion or is it
simply that we've gone too far and now
is the moment for American democracy to
switch back as at some point in the
future we may need again to switch back
towards this direction but there's no
question that the regulator's failed to
exercise their powers and to regulate so
there's been their regulatory failure
you now have a financial crisis maybe
serious recession there's a great danger
now that you go to the other extreme of
re-regulating too far when you had the
Great Depression the entire banking
system was put in a straitjacket and he
stayed in that straitjacket until 1972
that was the tame and Liston invited
security analysts and told them that
actually banking can be a growth
industry so that was the the border said
let's say so until then the banking was
frozen so we don't want to go back there
because even though markets are
imperfect regulators are also human and
worse than that they are very erratic so
they are much slower in adjusting to
changing circumstances so we need to
improve our regular regulations there's
no question regulators have failed to
exercise their powers we must now learn
to regulate credit as well as money but
rely on the market mechanism to the
greatest possible extent so I'm often
taken to task for criticizing capitalism
then I'm myself known as a capitalist
and I'm doing that because I want
capitalism to survive it's a much better
then there's central banking it was the
failure of communism socialism that led
to the excess of market fundamentalism
now we must have abandoned that we have
to realize that markets are not perfect
but we mustn't fall back into the other
mistake but George I think you know
behind well bees question is the
following you know we can agree that the
US economy in 1972 had not enough
leverage well that Ananda de Soto's Peru
has not enough leverage but do we really
know how much the right level is and if
we don't really know and I think you
would say that human perceptions are
always fallible and we can't be sure
shouldn't we decentralize that choice to
individual borrowers rather than having
regulators step in and set some
necessarily arbitrary amount of
borrowing that is deemed to be the right
balance between on the one hand cheap
capital and on the other hand too much
risk no you see very reasonable argument
but if you leave it to the individual
market participants bankers and so on
they they they will go to excess and
then you have got to save the system and
you have to bail them out and that
creates what is now recognized as the
moral hazard right now in so if you are
subject to being bailed out you are
receiving protection from the
authorities whether you recognize it or
not and therefore you have to be also
subject to some regulation because it's
really the job of the regulator's not to
have to bail out the system so credit
creation inherently involves this
potential boom-bust bubble aspect and
you have to control the bubble and the
and the growing side so you don't have
to take all the pain but that comes with
the bursting of the bubble so that's
what the that's the reason I would give
why you have to control leverage and of
course the control will never be a
perfect but we definitely if you leave
it to the markets they will
over-leveraged and they did should they
control the leverage of your fund
indirectly yes bye-bye
adjusting the reserve requirements that
banks have to keep depending on the
leverage employed by the by the by the
by the borrower so a less leveraged
funds would require less a minimum
reserve requirement and the more
leveraged fund would require more and
then you couldn't have the over
leveraging that you have had I want to
take another question from the floor I
want to remind you though before we
close that this is going to be this has
been on the record this session so let's
take a last question right there for
that
thank you very much you have emphasized
in your conversation with Sebastian that
the US consumer has been the engine of
global growth you also pointed out that
thanks to exports we have so far avoided
falling into the recession my question
is whether you envision more opportunity
for the United States to be a greater
exporter and greater producer as opposed
to consumer both with with regards to
manufactured goods as well as
agricultural goods and if so in spite of
the rising oil prices whether you see
there is an opportunity for a shift of
u.s. fortunes more towards production
yes definitely that's the process we are
now in a process of adjustment it's like
a junkie coming off drug abuse it's a
painful process but it is it is actually
happening in other words our current
account deficit is shrinking and quite
substantially and I think it will
inevitably have to shrink more if the
rest of the world is not willing to to
support our habit maybe we've got time
for one more and we can write you
anything
I'm sorry you had an you've already
asked the question was that let me just
is there anyone else who wants to forget
it was your neighbor okay I take it back
thank you I'm Robert Hurst ein regarding
the reflow of investment from abroad do
you feel that the US policy should be
any different toward investment by
market players on the one hand and
invest
by state controlled enterprises or
investment vehicles on the other and if
so how do we find that that line and how
do we implement it well I think that we
obviously need to remain open to
investment from from abroad sovereign
wealth funds create posed a problem
because there could be political
motivations other than commercial
motivations so that that is an issue
that needs to be handled and there needs
to be certain standards of transparency
and and it is actually being worked out
and I think that that sovereign wealth
funds that abide by those principles
should be freed to invest like any like
any other institutional investor well
thank you very much trust our guest
George Soros thank you to all of you for
coming